thank you so much for being here Steve
it's a pleasure now you know I have been
as you know I've been a big fan of yours
for such a long time you've done so much
brilliant work and you're you're
becoming well-known in this country but
you are a massive star in the United
Kingdom is that not true if you say so
many people come to you probably and say
Steve Coogan he's the authority on
what's funny what's not funny
do you get that a lot too you have a
little trying things on you and they
want your opinion yeah well let what
they do people will come up to me in a
store if I'm shopping or if if I'm I
sometimes take the underground the tube
in London and some other side lots of
Minister yeah they've they've recognised
me and they say it's okay I won't blow
your cover when they are a funny story
and then I think oh my god it's not
sweating cuz I'm not gonna have to laugh
at it right but the work the work
because I want to offend them and think
like I'm an arrogant so-and-so no and
but the worst time having two is the
Edinburgh Festival where a lot of comedy
goes on big big comedy festival and some
guys said you've got to come see a show
you've got to come see our show and I
was like okay and I went to see the show
and it stank yeah and I thought what I
don't want to hang around and say speak
to them afterwards I don't know what to
say
because it'll be embarrassing and I
don't want to lie and so I sneaked tried
to sneak out the theater I snuck down
the stairs and I was trying to find a
way out and this is terrible because I
was with my professor let's let's just
go early soon as the applause the
curtain came down I was down the stairs
and they said which is the way out I
said I think it's this door and I opened
the door and walk straight into their
dressing room and they were Steve I went
it was fantastic I said do I think so it
was brilliant yeah your voice gets
higher than more you live what was your
you know I was talking to Daniel about
he come from England you come to this
country it seems like such a strange
place in some ways what was your first
impression of America well I'm sort of
quite used to it now but when I was
growing up I thought I thought I knew
what America was like because I watched
Kojak yeah so I knew what about things
like Murder She Wrote yeah it's a
slightly narrower frame of cop
for a reference even than code yeah but
you're younger than me and you point to
that favor I'm more successful let's
just get it out in the open and say no
my first impressions of AmeriCorps
actually when I was the first one was
was when my sister came to America in
1977 on holiday and and it was a bit not
many people travel to America mingle in
those days and she came back and she
she'd got off the plane and we picked
over the airport move like what's
America like what's it like and she said
she said it's amazing she said they get
hot pizza delivered to their front door
what what cooked ready to eat you mean
we're having Joe brought to your homes
in England yeah materials
well yeah oh yeah yeah we have we have
tinned food the kind of food you keep in
a nuclear bunker and and they walked out
but this was like too crazy and she said
and the other thing is these sometimes
they go out for breakfast and that just
blew our minds do that anywhere you see
an option
yeah oh I mean you could know you could
go to the supermarket and buy something
and come back and make some poached eggs
but you couldn't you can't go and people
do now of course we all have cappuccinos
we're incredibly sophisticated now did
your sister bring you souvenirs did she
bring you things back from America
thanks for the prompt this is it right
here
this is seamless yeah and then what
happened
[Applause]
seamless things I was going to talk the
very first talk show I did in England a
guy would say you know say we're trying
to segue into impressions and now what
would Bob Geldof say if he were here
right now this is a terrible segue but
but yes no thank you
you know where does it say touch leg do
you know whatever what I do that it's
only fills me with a confidence and an
energy you know what I took your life so
about the same way I'm straight by the
way but ya know did your sister bring
you any souvenirs
[Applause]